want to just not spend a lot of time on
this but i do want to show you one other
clip a bunch of people wrote in asking
me to talk about this one uh former
trump national security adviser michael
flynn uh suggests that there is going to
be sort of like um secret vaccination
done of people by putting the vaccine in
salad dressing he said he heard that our
friend john amato over at crooks and
liars wrote this up michael flynn is
insane says vaccine is in salad dressing
michael flynn's latest crazy deep state
spiking your salad dressing with covet
vaccine this was on
i don't even know what show this was on
uh it looks to be some kind of like
bogus medical and
financial consultation type show the ads
on the screen say uh something about
protect your health with heard help from
sherwood tv
and meehan md vladimir zelenko md
protect your wealth with help from
andrew zorkini
um
i don't even know where these where do
they even find these shows i don't know
but here is michael flynn talking about
i guess some kind of deep state putting
vaccine vaccines in salad dressing
does drinking the vaccine even do the
same thing as injecting it it all sounds
very stupid but here's michael flynn and
you'll notice so remember remember
former national security adviser michael
flynn this was the top national security
official in the country for a short
period of time he's also wearing a shirt
that has his own name on it it says
flynn it's weird it real i mean i i
gotta put you know somebody sent me a
thing this morning where they're talking
about putting the vaccine into salad
dressing or salads have you seen this
yes have you seen this i mean it's and
i'm thinking to myself
this is the bizarro world right this is
definitely the bizarre world so there's
the seriousness of what this what this
professional realized he was doing wrong
and he and he's now you know he's found
a new way and then there's the there's
this the laughability
on the other extreme that people are i
mean these people are seriously thinking
about how to impose their will on us uh
in our society and it's and it's
a choice yeah so there is no plan to put
the vaccine into salad dressing uh but
also yeah
i mean i don't i don't know that this is
really even relevant but
the people we would need to trick into
taking the vaccine
are probably more likely to have it in a
hot dog than in a salad if you
understand what i'm saying so like if
this was your approach i'd be looking at
maybe injecting the vaccine into a
frankfurter
uh rather rather than mixing it into
salad dressing it just might take i
think the folks are more likely to reach
for the dog than the salad but that's
probably probably a different issue
there is no such plan of course and it's
completely absurd and who even watches
these shows like there's a lot of these
shows that are either
religiously oriented financial advice
or religiously oriented medical advice
or just quackery
and they seem to get donations i don't
know who is watching and who would who
would be watching in a serious way like
we monitor these shows
in a sort of satirical sense like like
the horror of it
but somebody must be contributing to
this stuff and also
if they get michael flynn on maybe we
can get michael flynn on right i mean
these shows don't seem to have much of
an audience maybe michael flynn would be
willing to appear with me uh i would be
glad to speak to him i think that would
be absolutely great
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light glasses i've sometimes had issues
falling asleep at night eventually
realize some of it might be coming from
the blue light emitted by my phone and
computer screens peer-reviewed studies
show blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your sleep rhythms are
disturbed i've seen a lot of improvement
since i started using blue light glasses
from blue blocks most companies make
blue light glasses in a mass-produced
way with no quality standards but blue
blocks glasses are made in actual optics
labs in their australian headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version non-prescription even reading
glasses and for every pair of glasses
blue block cells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath the video
and there's also free shipping worldwide
on orders over 115 dollars